gourguechon fait de boeuf nourries à
l'herbe avez vous vu cette publicité
vantant les burgers fait de boeuf
nourries à l'herbe jlw on n'est pas dans
un champ avec nos bons ingrédients mais
là je le suis parce qu'à partir de
maintenant tout le boeuf servi chez nous
et nourries à l'herbe cette publicité a
piqué notre curiosité
on a posé la question à la chef de la
direction d'ing w canada vous nous dites
d'un ami pubis et qu'ils sont nourris
uniquement à l'ère des seulement à
l'herbe oui j'aime et céréales qui
entrent en ligne de compte celui de neuf
points ce qui énerve c'est celle au
besoin et puis 6,6 à des températures
extrêmes là c'est sûr qu'on va permettre
de temporairement quelques jours de
nourrir avec les céréales ccc geste
accusant
la grande question pourquoi du boeuf
nourries à l'herbe qu'est ce que ça
change dans la vie que c'est une façon
naturelle pour les détails de sa mort et
moi je trouve cette façon c'est un cycle
qui précise qu en birmanie
mais produisons nous suffisamment de
buzz nourries à l'herbe pour fournir
tous les a et w du canada vérification
faite on en produit très peu
habituellement les bus du canada sont
bien nourris à l'herbe mais sont
engraissés mais ce grand a et w doit
donc importer du boeuf des états unis et
doux si loin que l'australie et la
nouvelle-zélande comment je peux me dire
qu'un acheteur brin nourries à l'herbe
qui vient de la nouvelle-zélande
l'australie je fais un geste pour
l'environnement
c'est très clair comme nous entraînent
dans leur recherche c'est très clair
l'idée est que ça ne représente au
niveau de la compétition et génératrice
à l'heure des vacances
et oui même si c'est un mythe même si ça
vient d'ailleurs c'est ce que ma
préférence c'est d'encourager l'économie
canadienne c'est pour ça qu'on veut
faire ce changement de ces virages lents
et cet investissement dans ici
parce que pour l'instant s'appelle quoi
la proportion qui est du canada puis qui
leur est il que vous devez importés si
c'est sûr que la balise selon démontrait
voix y avoir deux trois années avant
d'être à 100% mais autorise les 100%
nous voici à la ferme à l'herbe à pont
rouge près de québec
chez nous on ne nourrit aucun regret
aucune moulis est vraiment au jour de
l'herbe c'est soit que les friches
directement au pâturage soit qu'elle ait
récolté
pour le moment le bétail de dominique ne
finit pas entre deux tranches de pain
chez a et w cie avec ew me dit moi je
vais prendre dix mille livres de viande
hachée ben moi tout le reste de la
carcasse il faut que je fasse quelque
chose avait donc je m'en fous je
prendrai pas le filet mignon pour
envoyer un avion dash est donc le
faudrait que je me trouve un marché pour
mon filet mignon pour m'aimer mais parti
plus à mijoter à bouillir un steak c'est
sûr que notre marché est vraiment direct
un circuit qui est très très court
consommateurs il va ya pas plus courts
que ceux quand on rajoute des
intermédiaires bello souvent ça prend
des volumes de production s'apprendre
l'uniformité ce après toute une
logistique qui est différente
dominique pratiquent l'agriculture
régénératrice depuis 2008 on change nos
animaux de parcelles environ quatre fois
par jour donc sont toujours dans une
herbe qui ferait ch il ya tellement de
gains aller chercher au niveau d'une
bonne gestion passage que ce soit autant
au niveau financier au niveau de la
qualité de la viande et de tout l'impact
environnemental aussi en nourrissant les
boeufs à lherm on encourage ces
castrations carbone au sol qui est une
façon très bonne pour réduire les
émissions en cause des fêtes
raymond desjardins et colauréat du prix
nobel de la paix pour sa contribution au
sein du groupe d'experts sur le climat
le giec une fois que les jambes on est
encouragé à faire ce genre de choses là
parlent un peu un peu d'argent des sites
et amis vont évoluer dans cette
direction en haute loire c'est une bonne
nouvelle pour l'environnement
à condition que le duff soit élevé
localement et non pas l'autre bout de la
planète
voit que à w on rapporte finesse et ils
voient que les jeunes sont très
intéressés à des choses comme le boeuf
nourri à terme alors je crois qu'ils
sont tous repartis disque
qu'environnementaux quand même
incroyable de penser qu on importe du
boeuf la bête et ça reste quand même
écologue économique et écologique de
transporter des du bétail de
lydec un condensé de trouver des façons
d'investissement bear canadien et tu
essaies si ce qui fonctionne de plus en
plus on voit que c'est possible parce
que nos pays le font pourquoi pas le
canada
[Musique]
du côté du groupe de québec on ne relève
pas d'engouement marqué pour le boeuf
nourries à l'herbe je vois pas l'intérêt
de pour la saveur pour la qualité du
produit une zone dense on a axé sur
trois axes la qualité du produit
l'environnement puis le
le côté local pour moi ça répond pas ni
l'un ni l'autre de ces cette partie de
nous autres on essaie de répondre à la
demande spécifique relier réel à la
tendance commerciale nord américaines
alors un boeuf a l'air de classe qu'au
foot ne sera pas classée selon les
normes double ou triple il va être
déclassé tout simplement rentrer au tac
aux la couleur du gras à cause de la
taille de la carcasse puis aussi parce
qu' il serait pas aussi persillé
généralement au niveau du groupe
quelques pièces de viande de boeuf
nourries à l'herbe nous attendent chez
dominique et son conjoint frédéric
frédéric c'est dominique qui élève puis
vous qu'ils mangent et c'est ça oui ça
ressemble à ça mais c'est différent de
la viande d'élevage conventionnelle
légèrement witty si on compare à bieber
conventionnel il ya peut-être un petit
peu moins de deux personnages de gros
c'est une viande maigre
donc ça paraît dans la viande
[Musique]
sa saveur des fois j'ai des clients plus
âgés qu'ils exercent à ça ça goûte le
boeuf de quand j'étais petit c'est jade
à dire c'est plus goûteux mais on
m'avait dit que ça peut être plus
goûteux ferreux mais je sens pas
souffert là dont on adhère parlez-leur
je consommais nous savourons l'on nous
at on dit il faut réduire la convention
viande et si on est pour à manger on
devra manger la viande des animaux ndlr
va falloir le système évolue évolué ce
mais on voit qu'il ya en plusieurs
petits groupes de fermiers qui font ça
et j'ai faut les encourager
c'est que le type de firmes qu'on se
reproduise un peu comme il ya eu une
vague de reproduction de fermes
maraîchères avec les paniers de légumes
y en avait quelques-uns au début puis
après ça s'est popularisé les la halle à
la clientèle au connu ce type de deux
produits le pipi l'offre suivi aussi
m